[Music]
vanessa bryant is having a major fashion
moment in italy the 39 year old beauty
stunned in a dark teal satin gown while
attending dolce gabbana's show held at
st mark square in venice
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
vanessa was one of the many stars who
turned out in style for the event she
shared a few snaps with her famous
friends including
sierra jennifer lopez zoe saldana and
jennifer hudson vanessa among the other
stars arrived to the soiree by boat she
shared a glimpse of the star-studded
ride which also included fast and
furious star vin diesel on instagram
[Music]
following the big night vanessa had
dinner at cipriani's with her boat
buddies plus kris jenner and boyfriend
corey gamble chris captioned this pic
middle of the night shenanigans in
venice with this crew vanessa's
glamorous italian day was capped off by
a sleepover with her bestie sierra
dave
you woke me up
i did not yes you did the phone woke you
up
earlier this month vanessa and her
daughters natalia capri and bianca had a
european getaway of their own the family
visited croatia monaco france and
fittingly spent some time in capri italy
in capri vanessa recreated a throwback
vacation photo of her eldest kids with
kobe bryant natalia and the late gianna
sitting on a beautiful tile bench that's
covered in hand-painted lemons and art
the proud mom shared the pick of her
youngest bianca and capri wearing
matching lemon dresses and sitting in
the same place honoring the memory all
these years later she captioned it
missing my baby girl gigi my number two
mamba sita before the trip vanessa
shared with her followers that before
kobe died the nba legend gave natalya
the green light to go on a trip to
croatia with her senior high school
class sadly that adventure was cancelled
due to the coronavirus pandemic but
vanessa kept the dream alive and made it
a reality sharing on instagram i wanted
to make sure that natalia bryant got the
opportunity to visit it's beautiful
[Music]